the generation of thinkers that produced
Kalb in that producer modern-day labor
party have fundamentally failed
[Music]
welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster i'm konstantine kissin and this
is a show for you if you're bored with
people arguing on the internet of
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are brilliant
guests this week is a returning guest to
trigonometry in the wake of the election
we're delighted to have him back he's a
professor at the University of Kent and
the author of national populism a revolt
against liberal democracy Mike Goodwin
welcome back to trigonometry thanks for
having me again to have you back there
was a long intro I hope I got all of a
riah I'm pretty sure I have yeah we're
delighted to have you back it's been a
week since the election as we're
recording this what went wrong or what
went right well it's been a week already
yes okay I'm still sort of in the
whirlwind of post-election chaos what
look I mean this was a realignment
election in many ways this was the
largest conservative majority since 1987
their high share of the vote since 1979
and interestingly for me actually it was
the fourth consecutive time that the
conservative vote share increased since
2010 now we've got a nice whole
literature on the costs of governing and
incumbency effects and parties that are
in government tending to lose this was a
curious case of a incumbent party
actually increasing its food share but
for labor I mean the mic was absolutely
devastating worst performance since 1935
has now you know people keep saying to
me this is like 1983 Michael foot it's a
lot worse for later for the 1983 1983
they still had they were still the
largest party in Scotland they still had
most of their northern heartlands but
now labour are being really chased out
of both of those things and listening to
the prospective leadership candidate
this week after the election I don't
think anybody has a convincing coherent
explanation for why the Labour Party is
in this mess and I'm sure we'll will
come back to that the other thing here
about this election was just looking at
the role of class looking at just how
successful a party led by a graduate of
Eton and Oxford was among the working
class going into those labour Heartland
areas you know Blythe Valley Don Valley
Wakefield and converting areas that in
some cases haven't been conservative
since the 1930s and others cases haven't
been conservative at any other point in
our political history and and so on one
level this is about British politics but
obviously on another level this is about
the broader realignment the new culture
divide in our politics that is sweeping
across many advanced Western democracies
and we saw a Conservative Party really
cleaning up in areas that the Labour
Party had been founded to represent and
that now really has ushered in an
existential crisis to a party that still
defines itself as a working class party
but is really no more a party of the
working class it's an incredible
transformation and before you jump in
France I just want to ask this it's you
talk about the realignment and really I
think this is the bit in your book which
we talked about all of this you've
predicted you've been predicting this
stuff for 15-20 years I think it's fair
to say in fact you actually advised ed
Miliband and his team about this right
and it doesn't seem like they
particularly listen today well that's
that's quite an interesting story go
back five years ago we wrote a book
myself a Robert Ford at the University
of Manchester wrote a book called revolt
on the Rights which was basically
looking at the rise of new divides in
Britain in particularly the rise of
Nigel Farage in the UK Independence
Party but it was more about actually how
British politics and society were
changing and one of the key arguments of
that book essentially is that you have a
large number of voters that felt left
behind not just economically which is
where the left goes wrong they only can
view this in terms of economics but
actually they felt left behind in terms
of their values that there had been a
new set of socially
actually liberal values that they
neither shared nor respected that was
now being imposed upon them by political
elites and the media and they felt like
they couldn't really relate to those
values whether it's sort of strong
support for the European Union strong
support for large-scale migration you
know and all the new identity politics
stuff that you talk a lot about on your
show and when we came out with this book
and we said look actually Labor's got to
worry about this just as much as the
Conservatives because the dominant view
at that point was a nigel farage and you
could were really only hitting the
Conservatives and a lot of Labour MPs
are very cross about here we've got a
lot of criticism and randomly one day I
got an email saying you know do you want
to come and present the findings of the
book to Ed Miliband's team and this was
this was just before the 2014 European
Parliament elections when of course
Farraj did did very well and Labour did
very poorly and anyway so Rob and I went
in and we presented to Ed Miliband's
advisors and we finished his
presentation explaining why Labour's
relationship with the working class was
weakening and why they they were
basically in for a long term problem
from Euro skepticism and unsocial
conservativism and it finished and there
wasn't a single question just silence
thank you very much
that's very interesting see you later
it's not one of my gigs but then on the
same day I think it was we walked across
the street and presented the same exact
same presentation to Linton Crosby who
at that time was running David Cameron's
election campaigning I think it was on
the same day and because you know we
have to offer a search to all the
parties and you know make sure everybody
has a chance to talk about it and it
Linda Crosby was the only person in the
room and Rob and I saw presented it and
at the end of the presentation I mean I
we got a grilling that you really only
get if you present papers at the sort of
infamous seminars in Oxford or
you know Cambridge I mean he was really
on it you know how did you measure this
when did that happen
what do they think about this what are
they think about that and I remember
walking out and just thinking my guy
really really knows his stuff
really really see what was coming and I
think on the labor side there was this
entrenched resistance to accepting that
their electorate had become structurally
unsound but also the only interpretation
they had that could make sense was to
draw on the kind of old Marxist lines
and say well this is basically just
about economic insecurity and let's just
give these people better wages and you
know let's just talk about this in terms
of a growth story an austerity story
whereas what the right had understood is
that actually this was much more a story
about values and people feeling as
though their identities were being
challenged by these new issues migration
EU membership globalization and so on
and that day in effect really tells us a
lot about what happened over the next
five years because as we now discovered
you know labor Labor's relationship
really has become much weaker with its
traditional heartlands and it's a story
that's about sequencing right I mean
listening to the perspective post called
in leadership candidates say this is
just about brexit this is just about
what happened during the 2019 campaign
this is just about Jeremy Corbyn
actually the evidence is very clear what
happens is basically from the late 90s
early 2000s you get the rise of new
labor and blare the differences between
the parties become blurred people stop
talking about class differences so much
including the media post 2001 you then
start seeing working-class voters
abstaining not voting anywhere near the
same levels that they had been
previously and as you go through the
2000s you can begin to see something is
fundamentally wrong in the labour
heartlands then enter Farraj you keep
start to cultivate those areas
disrupting those long term tribal
allegiances and you go through the
coalition government with Farraj going
into these labor areas hayward a middle
turn
the Northeast and parts of the Midlands
and basically cultivating this
disillusionment this sense that there is
this distant metropolitan elite that's
no longer interested in your life and
then by the time you get into 2015 and
Cameron he actually scoops up quite a
lot of those voters but by the time he
gets 2016 and the referendum a lot of
those areas as we now know 60% were then
60% of labour health seats opted to
leave the European Union and a lot of
people who had given up on politics came
back into politics to vote for brexit so
then by the time Johnson turns up right
and Dominic Cummings turn out what
they've effectively diagnose I mean Nick
Timothy reached the same conclusion but
the execution was very poor but what
they what they recognized was that in
effect the stage had been set for a much
wider realignment and crucially they
made a strategic change they held the
line on questions of culture and
identity by saying we will deliver
brexit we will reform migration we will
toughen up on crime we will clamp down
on Islamist terrorists but on the
economic axis they leaned a little bit
more left they said we're going to
increase spending in the NHS increase
spending on infrastructure raise the
minimum wage tackle regional
inequalities reboot the northern
powerhouse and what they grasped was a
fundamental new rule of politics which
is that it's easier for the right to
move left on economics than it is for
the left to move right on identity and
culture and they the good heart and Eric
Hoffman and myself and others have been
making this argument for many many years
including on the show including on the
show which is that the labor the labor
party simply no longer has the
vocabulary that is needed to reconnect
with these voters that don't just want
to talk about economic insecurity but
they want to talk as much about cultural
insecurity and this election to me I
think really hammered home those key
messages and that's why I don't think
there will be any quick recovery for the
Labor Party because listening to the
prospective leadership candidates they
just have a they just
that cannot comprehend what's happened
and why it's happened so I think we're
in for an interesting ride do you think
part of it as well and I'm going to use
quite unkind word to describe some of
the Labour Party members is cowardice
that they're not willing to address
these issues that the moment you have
working-class people come to them and
talk about things like immigration and
their fears they don't know how to deal
with it so they slap the races and word
the intolerance of bigotry and therefore
they can just dismiss it well I think in
effect what's been happening I'm won
over by thomas piketty's a lot about
inequality but that is now I think will
recently been looking at the way our
parties have evolved I'm won over by his
argument that in effect what happened
prior to 2019 was that our two main
parties had been captured and on the
Left the Labour Party had been captured
by a highly socially culturally liberal
Brahmin left that was in effect more
interested in identity politics wasn't
particularly bothered about economic
redistribution had come through the
elite universities the elite social
networks was broadly insulated from the
effects of globalization and was really
only interested in expressing virtue and
moral superiority and certainly not
really that interested in expressing
class or economic solidarity with with
workers but on the right at the same
time the conservative center-right
parties had been captured by this
merchant elite of business elite that
was really only interested in
deregulation economic liberalism putting
free-market capitalism on steroids and
piketty's argument certainly is
convincing in that that basically leaves
a large number of voters millions of
voters around the world basically not
represented because your average voter
instinctively wants a little bit more
economic protection and a little bit
more cultural protection that's
basically the winning formula of our of
our time and I would argue that cultures
in the driving seat and economics is
sitting next door
in the passenger seat still playing a
role but not quite as dominant as
culture and then you know what what's
interesting about that is Johnson and
Cummings basically they're recognized
that that wasn't going to be able to get
them the territory in the seats that
they needed and they needed to in effect
return more to the sort of Disraeli
tradition of conservative politics and a
thatcher tradition and that really
unlocks the the door to a lot of those
labor leave seats and so prior to this
election a lot of left-wing parties in
europe because social democracy is
fundamentally in crisis i mean the
people who say this is all about jeremy
corbyn this is all about brexit one of
the i think one of the interesting
questions they all ignore is well why is
social democracy in general in crisis
why are center-left parties across much
of europe in decline because this is
fundamentally about a structural problem
within their electorate you can't hold
together middle-class liberal
professionals traditional socially
conservative workers and then students
you know so generation Z Millennials in
this kind of broad tent when they hold
irreconcilable values and attitudes on
these new identity issues you just can't
do that and so I think labor don't
really have an answer to that social
democracies being in decline lots of
people on the Left were looking to call
binners gee maybe this guy has the
answer center-right parties are looking
at Johnson and the Conservatives and
saying well maybe this cross-class
coalition this kind of British version
of Christian democracy in a strange kind
of way maybe this is a compelling
formula for conservative parties to
navigate through these newvalue divides
and you know this was the first culture
war remember after the financial crisis
and the liberal left has lost the first
culture war that emerged after the
collapse of Lehman Brothers the crisis
and austerity and and it by extension
it's kind of smashed the central thesis
that many on the Left have held that you
know this is still fundamentally about
voters who are driven by
my economic cost-benefit calculations
and ever since we shared that research
with Miliband going in any countless
numbers of times to Parliament so talked
to Labour MPs about how they needed to
change their position on freedom of
movement how they needed to change their
change their representation of
working-class communities because the
party has been basically dominated
gradually over time by middle-class
university educated MPs and and they
would sort of say oh yeah oh we get it
we get it and then nothing sort of
changes just carries on the same because
like I say they don't have the
vocabulary but also they don't have the
they don't have the everyday experience
to understand where most voters are on
these issues is easier to say you know
it's racist it's it's ignorant it's it's
bigotry and the more and more they do
that which is why identity politics is
so important here the more and more they
are saying to these communities that you
are not equal to others or the in effect
you know you are probably you are
problematic communities don't be
surprised if they abandon abandon you
want mass well that was the most common
comment that people were making on
social media I mean you made this
viewing that's I'll let you do
well no it's well I made the point that
you know it's it's amazing that you know
you demonize a whole swath of you know
communities of people is racist and
tolerant and thick and then get a bit
upset when they don't bother it's as
simple as that really
but what's ironic is they appointed
somebody who you could set one level
with socially conservative Pro brexit
ear old-school left-wing as we as we
would deem him and then they didn't
allow him to be any of those things
Juden they would have done better if
they just let call ben b call Ben I
think or Ben will be seen as a very
interesting moment in British politics I
think albanism I don't actually I don't
actually disagree with everything that
the Labour Party today are saying
particularly on
the economy I think there's a very
strong case for going much further with
economic reform than we have done in
this of course is partly why Blair is
still the architect of this period of
turbulence and chaos because when when
labor were in power for such a long
period of time they really didn't do
enough to reform financial services to
deal with regional inequality to
rebalance what many voters out there see
as being a rigged economic settlement
and in some ways a right to fill that
but I think you know Corbin the problem
with labor generally today is Corbin's
right in a way to say we've got to turn
up the volume on economic radicalism but
they've matched that with this sort of
social cultural liberalism which a lot
of voters out there now see as being the
fundamental problem with the direction
of our society so they can't they're
constantly now going to be outflanked by
a center-right that is now going to
speak on both of those flanks it's going
to say we are going to intervene a
little bit more to - you know reboot
that local economy in the regions but we
also now accept and recognize your
desire for an australian-based point
system a tougher approach on life crime
whatever it is right and so the Labour
Party cannot cannot meet the
Conservatives toe-to-toe on those issues
what they should do in my view at least
I mean this is where you know you get
into a really interesting debate within
academia because well I think the Labour
Party needs to do is basically at least
over the short term you can hold the
economic line but they're going to have
to change the cultural line they're
going to have to accept that we can't
have freedom of movement anymore we
can't have this never-ending expansion
of social liberalism and identity
politics it's just not going to work
anymore and they can try and get away
from this narrative that is obsessed
with defining everybody according to how
they're different from one another to
actually getting back to a narrative
that talks about communal and social
solidarity and what we
in common which which is what Obama and
Blair and now ironically Johnson have
had done so well which is they're
talking about much broader identities
that are above just saying well you know
you're white male struggling with toxic
masculinity unless the Labour Party
actually realistically adjusts as some
center-left parties in Europe have done
then they will never get over this
fragmented electorate and of course what
academics will argue at this point is
some academics will say oh well you're
legitimizing or you're normalizing white
supremacism and white nationalism and
that is actually part of the problem
because the Labour Party and left-wing
parties are often most strongly
connected to and influenced by thinkers
that hold the most extreme
interpretation of society and are the
most committed true believers to the
sort of post sixties identity left
school of thought right and and that's
that's where the first thing labor the
Labour Party should do is completely
renew revitalize refresh the people that
is talking to because it yeah I mean the
generation of thinkers that produced
call been that produce a modern-day
Labour Party have fundamentally failed
and they need to start putting
themselves in rooms with thinkers and
analysts that hold a very different
interpretation of where Britain is and
where it's going and they need to start
putting themselves out outside of their
comfort zone post 2016 the liberal left
I would argue has basically covered
itself in comfort blankets its Cambridge
analytic ah it's Russia its brac say
it's cool being it's the big brexit bus
it's 350 million
nobody has seriously stepped back and
looked at how the underlying deeper
currents are reshaping our societies and
introducing these new tensions into that
liberal left electorate and until they
start doing that they're not going to be
able to devise a road map
to power you know they're just going to
be going round and round in these
circles allowing the right that how to
recognize these new fundamental rules in
politics to to enjoy new period of
dominance I think the problem is as one
that it's like you're saying you know
they need to do that but I know these
people we are in an industry which is
which is riddled with them and let's be
honest they'd show no intention of doing
that I don't think that I think there
are people who get it I think if you
look at the Britain's labor movement
there have been voices within it a new
labor blue labor John Kronus John Denham
has been very good on Englishness all
Embree who we've got on but none of
those are the momentum law well this is
a classic I mean this is John Mays law
of curvilinear disparity in a way in
that he argued in the 70s a problem with
parties is they get captured by
activists that are much more radical
than the electorate and what labor is in
is this is this great example really of
of a party that's been captured by an
activist base that is mainly London that
is mainly middle class that is mainly
university educated
hyper liberal yep so socially liberal it
has no resonance understanding of
Bolsover and blithe Valley and might
year I came I mean
academics I think have also struggled
because there is not much interaction
with those communities there's a lot of
survey work there's a lot of desk base
work there's a lot of insular
conversations that don't open up to
people who perhaps have a have an
on-the-ground understanding of those
communities and that's a problem I mean
it's an intellectual crisis as a
philosophical crisis as an existential
crisis for labour and after 83 it took
them three elections to get back in back
in the game and it may take three
elections this time but they've been out
since 2010 right and but let me ask you
this because this you mentioned that in
Europe some parties have made the
adjustment how how does a Labour Party
successfully make that adjustment now
give
in order to do what you're talking about
they would have to completely shed this
loony fringe that they've been wagged by
as a dog for some time now they would
have to let go of them they would have
to start addressing their concerns back
to ordinary to the concerns of ordinary
people they would have to start talking
to working-class voters in the north and
and elsewhere frankly how how would they
be let's say the Tory party on to
Johnson which is doing pretty much the
same things they're dressing the
cultural concerns and now as you say the
right is moving to the center and maybe
even to the left frankly if you look at
some of the policies on economics so how
are they is there even room for a Labour
Party anymore no I've got mean there's
lots of room for a party that says we
need to radically reform the economy we
need to radically tackle a concentration
of wealth and tax avoidance and tax
evasion but but we also need to do much
better at representing communities that
aren't part of what you might call the
liberal consensus I mean the liberal
consensus was really only ever shared by
a minority and that's you know liberals
routinely exaggerate there they're the
size of their tribe the economic social
consensus that in effect lets have you
know
let's open up markets and let's open up
borders is actually quite a fringe view
the problem is during the 2000s and so
on we sort of bought into this narrative
that this was now the dominant view and
of course we've now discovered
particularly since 2016 that it isn't so
I think for the Labor Party it means
that you know they need to start asking
themselves some pretty tough questions
about where has liberalism gone wrong is
it too individualistic
has it failed to satisfy people struggle
for recognition which we always argued
it did a very good job of of doing that
and you know the UH the reason that
liberal democracy everyone got very
excited about the new era of liberal
dominance in the 90s was because they
said you know it makes individuals feel
recognized
by giving them individual rights so it
makes you gives you meaning but secondly
it married itself with the most dynamic
economic system that that mans ever
created and we can now see how both of
those things have come unstuck because
we have generations of voters that don't
feel recognized but we also have
economic systems that are still as part
of their DNA generating inequalities and
so I think the Labour Party needs to
step back I mean it's remarkable the
pace at which they've moved this debate
into one of leadership and not one of my
ideas and ideas have left the building I
mean there's no kind of serious
discussion about how social democracy
can renew and revive itself
intellectually to navigate through these
era this era of value divides because my
thesis is we're at the beginning of a
period of realignment right that the the
issue the toxic debates we've had about
migration and brexit actually this is
the beginning of a new era in which
we're going to have more of these big
intense debates that are not so much
going to be about traditional questions
of economic redistribution they are
going to be fundamentally questions
about cultural insecurity and whether or
not you feel that you are being
protected amid the winds of
globalization and that's going to
involve things that you talk about on
your program regularly from you know
minority identities through to you know
demographic change and in the future of
populations that will go through some
profound shifts in our life type not you
know not over the horizon but in the
next 50 50 years or so and I think the
Labour Party isn't ready to think about
that because it is a project that was
designed to answer economic questions
but is now having to rewire itself to
answer cultural questions and it as you
say in France is it doesn't have it
doesn't have the personnel doesn't have
the fingers the vocabulary through which
it can begin to weave together answers
to those questions
now some Social Democrats and
Scandinavia for example have said
actually we will be a little bit more
socially conservative on these questions
because actually that
that will bring us power and with power
we can tackle economic redistribution
and we can help workers but then in
other parts of the country I would say
Britain included there are parts of the
left that say no that's that's
normalizing wising power relations
you're in the other euro wilderness yeah
you're in the wilderness enjoy it enjoy
it because you're not going to have
power for a long period of time until
you recognize this new law will the
Tories be able to serve France or well
the Tories be able to hold together
their coalition because it's a very new
elektra for the Conservative Party as
well and by the way for American viewers
you think Republicans conservatives
Democrat labor to some extent I mean you
we'll talk more about that later maybe
it's a false analogy but how do they
hold together now under Boris Johnson
this coalition which is also a coalition
it's a coalition of working-class people
who are small see conservative who maybe
never voted for the Tory party ever
before and the kind of economic right
free-market people who who may have very
little in common well the first thing we
have to recognize has always been a
tradition of working-class voters
supporting the Conservative Party so we
shouldn't have been too surprised when
we saw Johnson go back to something that
Fatih also achieved in the 80s and this
is because conservatives inherently are
aspirational and optimistic and the
Labour Party at times is it is really
none of those things yourself carefully
because you got to play both sides to
some extent wearing a blue jumper so I
think that's always allowed the
Conservatives to have a shot at winning
over blue collar blue collar Britain and
there are going to be fundamental
tensions but I think the the advantage
the inbuilt advantage the Conservatives
have is that the tensions over the
economic model bowls over saying give me
more intervention and protectionism and
sorry enhance share saying you know I'm
fine I'm you know going to Rome this
weekend just give me a bit more economic
liberalism
those economic questions I don't think
the tension is as real within the
conservative electorate because what
those voters share is they they have a
lot more in common on the value
dimension so they are instinctively
socially conservative so they prioritize
stability and order and in general
conformity and they respect tradition
and they want to preserve ways of life
and they have that sort of in a Burkean
view of society and so I think that in
general there is a nimbu advantage for
the conservative so long as Johnson is
doing what he's doing which is going up
to Sedgefield and saying I get it you've
you've lent me your vote you know I'm
not taking this for granted I now need
to deliver on you know reviving coastal
Britain and fixing the regions and all
of those kinds of things but they now
the conservative tent fundamentally
still shares this basic consensus that
it is much better to sort of stress
stability over constant continual flux
and until the liberal left can tell
people clearly where it wants to take
them which does not sound like just
endless change endless globalization
endless endless fluctuation and
instability it's always going to
struggle in this era particularly to
meet conservatives head-on so I think it
will be a challenge for the
Conservatives to hold the electoral I
don't actually think it's going to be as
difficult as people think because
underpinning it at a foundational level
these voters actually you know do have a
lot in common if you put somebody from
Bolsover in a room with somebody from
you know Kensington and Chelsea right
they might disagree on on economics a
bit but they will fundamentally agree
those conservative voters on you know
let's moderate migration let's uphold
institutions let's do what we can to
stop someone like Jeremy Corbyn getting
into power let's let's prioritize
stability and order and tradition but if
you put a Labour voter from Hampstead in
a room with a Labour voter
one is providing social liberalism right
aggressively it defines itself you know
through this moral superiority complex
then forget about it there's no common
ground there at all if anything there's
just going to be this tendency to sort
of disdain look disdainfully and
negatively on on there it's like a world
comedian going to talk about brexit for
ten minutes somewhere up north or that's
basically what you're talking about just
yeah this is a fundamental value divide
but breaks it only breaks it to me
wasn't surprising I think I mean what
surprised me was the extent to which
people were surprised might break say
and what surprises me now is the extent
to which people are surprised by the
conservative well we weren't because
we've been talking to people like you
but it's amazing how ignorant people
were of this issue and the stuff that
you talk about more broadly I mean the
vast majority of people I know
completely didn't expect this I I bet
somebody 50-quid there was gonna happen
because to me it was just like a
no-brainer because having had the
conversation with you and with David
good heart and with Aaron Kaufman
it's just transparent isn't that I mean
you and I had no doubt that no no no we
we both knew that it was going to happen
but you know what these people do is
they ingest a narrative which you know
on the far left the momentum crowd and
then they just regurgitate this
narrative but it doesn't bear analyzing
and it's got my basis in reality but
it's to come in there what's also being
quite clear over the last week is that
they don't I mean be rude but they don't
read they don't actually engage with
research like for example here
capitalism a social democracy which is a
great book 1985 predicted all of this I
said you know social democracies
electorate is going to gradually over
time become increasingly incoherent and
divided between the expansion of the
university educated middle class and the
remaining socially conservative working
class voters and Social Democrat parties
will face a choice about how they manage
that and then in this country for the
last 25 years we've had loads of good
research Jeff Evans at Oxford James
Tilley Oliver Heath David cuts and
others
who have all shown the coming storm for
the Labour Party that you know that the
soil had been cultivated before Johnson
even became leader before may even
became leader of the Conservatives but
nobody was thinking seriously about how
to respond to that in a meaningful sense
and the only people who were you know
blue labour and and and others the only
people who were actually thinking about
this
well then sort of widely criticized and
disparage as being sort of sympathizers
of the right or being you know sort of
normalizes and and then you just realize
that I think you mentioned this earlier
alluded to it that there are people you
know the Labour Party needs to have a
very serious conversation but doesn't
really seem at all interested in having
that conversation it doesn't because it
goes back and you know I raised
Venezuela as an example you know they
have a narrative and once their
narrative no longer works then they
either shut down ignore it or they move
on to something else should be concerned
Matt because I personally believe that
whatever government is in power we need
a strong and credible opposition
challenge that absolutely and given what
you're saying it sounds like the Labour
Party is going to spend let's say a
decade in the wilderness at least Boris
Johnson has got a huge majority is he
going to be able to kind of just bull in
the china shop this and just do whatever
the hell he wants with no one really
opposing him properly I think I think I
completely agree with you what actually
make what worries me about British
politics is the is the weakness and the
incoherence of the opposition I mean the
post 2016 environment has been you know
dominated by a sort of socially
conservative worldview while the remain
camp the liberal left camp have
essentially been fragmented and divided
I really genuinely don't think that's a
good thing I would like to have a
vibrant strong opposition the problem
now I think for the liberal Left parties
is the Conservatives with the majority
they've got even though they won the
culture war they've not really
one the war that determines cultural
hegemony right so they are now I think
going to turn to asking deeper questions
not just about what's the policy program
but how do you push back against the
liberal left dominance that is reflected
in certain media out outlets is
reflected in certain educational
establishments and is the sort of high
culture and you know sort of soft left
norms how do you push back against that
so I think the challenge to the left as
we see it now in the rubble of the
election is electoral the challenge that
is coming is going to be fundamentally
intellectual and cultural and I can see
among conservatives after this election
there is now a real appetite for saying
there's no point winning elections if
over the long term you're still losing
the culture war you're still having all
of these key institutions and
educational establishments and elsewhere
they're still being captured right by a
view that undermines your long-term
success and credibility so I think the
Johnson government will probably now go
go further than most conservative
governments probably since the Thatcher
era it's saying it's not enough to pass
policy actually now there needs to be a
broader pushback against many of the
things you talk about in your program
state funding for non-work can be used
like trigonometry sounds good to me sign
the other canceling gender studies cream
Susan but there's a question I wanted to
ask you because we've been focusing a
lot on England which you know it's fine
and it's important written well but we
haven't spoken about Scotland actually
right okay I just know you're being
racist Scotland Scotland voted entirely
almost entirely for the SNP
are we gonna get another referendum and
if we do are we gonna say goodbye to
Scotland great quest I don't think we're
going to get one during this current
government I think the conservative and
unionist party will do everything within
its power to stop that from happening I
think as we go into 2020 the SNP is
going to have a number of distractions
and problems that's going to I think
expose you know some weaknesses within
the within within the movement and of
course I think for the Labour Party as
well you know what happened in Scotland
was so devastating because essentially
it takes away firstly it takes away
their ability to win a majority so the
best so labor government can open sorry
the Labour opposition can pay for the
labor opposition can hope for is is some
form of minority government on
parliament coalition and future but but
the second thing Scotland reminds us
about is just how quickly radical
political change can happen and how
comprehensive it can be and when you
look at other regions of the country you
look at Wales for example there was that
moment just before the election where it
looked like
Wales might begin to sort of move toward
a similar kind of realignment that we
that we saw in in Scotland and that
that's why I think it's significant I
don't think we're going to have a
referendum in the next few years but the
deeper questions I mean you know the
longer this goes on there is a much
deeper question to that we're going to
have to really interrogate which is what
where does all of this leave England and
where does all of this leave Englishness
and how we going to respond to a
movement that has for many years felt
that it is not represented politically
and socially and doesn't have
institutions in the same way that other
identities do and so I think Englishness
is going to come back onto the agenda
quite quite soon it's interesting it's a
great question by the room at Scotland I
thought you were gonna go to America not
when you were talking about it well let
me ask you this do you think the United
Kingdom will be the same configuration
in 20 or 30 years from now as it is now
I don't know you don't know I don't know
I I think we we have a fragmenting
settlement and that's very clear and I
think the Union in general is going to
struggle in a very significant way and
it comes back to that point about the
commonality and what are the shared
bonds that people in the United Kingdom
now have
and with these value divides because
they're becoming so because there's a
very strong regional dimension to them
what you've seen over the last few years
is that leave seats have gradually gone
further and further to the Conservatives
remain seats have gone further and
further towards labour and the lip lib
dems and of course in Scotland there is
a sort of a very strong kind of remain
majority anchored you know partly
through the SNP and I think your your
your seeing the kind of growing cracks
the widening cracks and it's not easy to
see how those are going to be put back
together especially when you consider
the brexit was only one manifestation of
these value divides so we've become
obsessed with the idea that brexit is
kind of all-encompassing and exclusive
but brexit is really only one spinoff
from these underlying value divides
between liberals and conservatives right
so there are going to be many others and
those two will hit the Union and they
will challenge the traditional
left-right
allegiances that we've had and they may
involve questions again about migration
and demographic change they might
involve questions around new minority
identities they might involve questions
around security and terrorism we don't
know where we'll be 30 40 years from now
but I think that is going to be
something again the main parties the
parties that win during this period of
value change of the parties that are
going to adapt and the parties that
don't adapt aka labour are going to
struggle and do you think moving on from
that are we going to face further than
well further pressure for a united
Ireland as well yeah I think so I think
so and I think watching how Ireland
responds over the next year or two years
with regards to the you know brexit now
being formalized and Post January remain
is going to transition into rejoin and
certain things that we spent three years
debating will be now final and certain
tactical battles will turn into
generational battles yes
and that's why actually by the way I
think a lot of people have found the
2019 elections so difficult because the
magnitude of what's been changed by the
result also with regards to Ireland is
so huge the people are only now
beginning to sort of think about it and
digest it let's look forward Matt and
one of the the biggest I think events of
next year will be the election campaign
in the United States where all of this
is gonna play out on what is a much
bigger stage
what do you see having again but just to
be clear for our viewers and listeners
you've been venting indicated and all
this stuff after talking about it for
many many many many years not the last
five years you've been talking about a
15 years at least what do you see
for that going forward and are we going
to see a kind of massive Trump victory
of Bojo style defeat for the Democrats
and first of all actually let me ask you
this how do you think they're gonna
respond are they gonna is the question
for them gonna be the lesson for us from
this labor loss is they didn't go far
enough left is that what they're gonna
think or are they gonna say no no we're
gonna we're gonna actually come back to
the center all I hope the Democrats
realize that going to the radical left
is not a vote winner telling a
working-class family in Wisconsin that
you might now have to pay more tax in
order to make reparations for the sins
of your ancestors that kind of stuff
it's not going to be a vote winner hold
on is it not a good idea to ask a
working-class person about their
pronouns I think also
[Laughter]
if we just take take the big debate now
of our time in a way and the but the
debate raging a social science and also
filtering out to these conversations is
well it's all of this change about
economics or is all of this change about
culture and everybody who's smart says
that's a ridiculous framework it's
clearly about how they both interact and
which one is dominant
I think 2020 in the u.s. is fascinating
because it gives us really a natural
experiment through which we can see
these economic concerns on the one hand
and these cultural concerns on the other
play out in real time Trump as I've
explained similar the only thing I mean
Trump and Johnson are completely
different characters and I won't waste
my time explaining why even though there
are lots of journalists mainly on the
liberal left that like to draw this
incredibly simplistic line because the
only thing they have is catastrophizing
that's the only thing certain people in
this debate now have which is it is a
return of fascism because that makes
them feel like they have this
self-importance that they've been
validated and that they are their
analysis is sort of superior to others
and they can't they don't have the
bandwidth and the the the thought power
to think anything else and it's anyway
so the u.s. 2020 election for me I mean
Trump has an inbuilt advantage right
he's talking about economic
protectionism and standing up to China
and he's talking about cultural
protectionism in terms of building the
wall clamping down on migration so he
has an inbuilt advantage and he may
struggle again to win the popular vote
but in the key constituencies that he's
going after that gives him an inbuilt
advantage the Democrats currently
similar to Corbin and labor are offering
economic redistribution with cultural
social liberalism in fact it's worse
than now it's like hyper liberalism as
that goldberg and people in the states
have been showing on Twitter
the liberal sections of the Liberal
Democrat Left have have responded to
2016 by doubling down in quite an
extreme way on their liberal outlook
becoming you know much more positive
toward minority groups becoming much
more hostile toward members of their own
group particularly sort of white
working-class voters becoming more
supportive of open borders and all of
these kinds of things in the same way
that remainders to a lesser degree
double down on their support for
migration and freedom of movement and so
on but that's not a convincing reply to
this moment that we're in because you're
never going to get these voters back on
side and I think if Trump ends up
winning again the reason I thought he'd
win the first time was because he was
speaking on these two dimensions that
that Clinton was unable to to to meet
but if he wins again I mean the
psychological blow to not just Democrats
but to liberalism is going to be huge
because it's going to tell us that
actually firstly they've completely
squandered and I group myself as a I'd
say on fairly liberal on some issues
that they squandered the post 2016
moment they have failed to find a
formula that can reconnect with voters
and repair those relationships and I
think it will be devastating if there is
a second defeat in the row in a row in
the same way that the Labour and Corbin
I think it's absolutely devastating that
after nearly a decade of conservative
power austerity in economic squeeze
ongoing inequality the best they could
do was you know the worst number of
seats since 1935 and these are massive
problems and now I think the u.s. 2020
will give us more evidence of that do
you think Boris Johnson and Trump I know
you say it's hard to make connections
between these two but they tap into
something deeper for me like I talk to a
lot of people on the left and I love
where they seem to be coming from is
that you should essentially should be
ashamed to be British you should be
ashamed to be American you should be
shame to be white our colonial past all
the rest of it and Johnson and Trump are
going now you should be proud to be
American you should be proud to be
British and that's a formal positive
message and a lot of the time so you
know we were at kill canonic so
economics festival in Ireland and a lot
of what these liberal economists seem to
be saying is that well it's it's the end
of the West it's the end of the America
it's what you're gonna do we're all
[ __ ] and then you have someone coming
on like Trump going absolutely not let's
make America great again
I think optimism is definitely part of
it we all have an optimism bias I mean
psychologists talk a lot about this
smokers convinced they'll never get lung
cancer there are not optimistic about
the the outcomes I think where the
Wrights or conservatives what they've
recognized I think firstly is that
people are far more attached still to
the nation than the liberal left
recognizes if you ask people in surveys
will you fight for your country if there
was a war tomorrow 80 90 percent say
absolutely you know do you feel proud to
live in your country all of those kinds
of metrics the nation for most people is
still fundamentally the one of the chief
reference points in their life and the
direction of parts of the liberal left
is is moving very quickly away from that
and isn't able then to speak to those
voters because it's just promising a
sort of diffuse confusing kind of
incoherent argument about moving to
supranational institutions and seemingly
not having a problem with more churn and
change and the disruption of the few
things that voters really really care
about tradition ways of life community
and belonging and then someone at this
point usually says well those things are
all proxy for races but but they're not
no they're really not and and and there
are races who vote for Trump and there
are races who vote for conservative
parties in Europe but but most people
are not and most people
actively distance themselves from those
expressions of intolerance and the more
that you're simply proclaiming to know
what what those people are and you're
adopting this sort of inaccurate
portrayal of them the more they're going
to backlash I mean then the one that one
of the most popular narratives on the
liberal left over the last 10 20 years
has been there is an inevitable liberal
destiny that is simply going to arrive
through migration and the rise of the
university educated middle class but
what and that narrative was very popular
when Trump was first just before
troubles first elected because people
like Stan Greenberg and other Democrats
were arguing there's absolutely no way
Trump can win because of this newly
ascendant liberal majority but of course
what that sent was a message to voters
that that really didn't want that
liberal majority that this was their
last chance their last chance to push
back against that that liberal consensus
that value set and they took it in the
same way that in the 2019 election in
Britain a lot of voters you know saw
this is quite a critical watershed
moment in a broader value struggle and
so they were willing to override their
traditional party loyalties because they
felt that on balance Johnson was
probably the horse to back in that
broader conflict I guess what I'm
hearing out of everything that you've
said today is that this is a correction
that has been coming for a very long
time because mindset particularly here
in London in the in the bubble of
Westminster and the cultural bubble that
Francis and I are in there are views as
a society have been shaped by a very
small number of people whose views are
completely not representative of the
rest of the country and the election of
Boris Johnson the election of Trump the
brexit referendum but potentially what
might happen in America next year this
is a correction against all of that the
way that I would view it is that the
post the 1960s liberal revolutions there
was a lot of overreach there was a lot
of overreach that when you
what started with very legitimate you
know concerns about minority rights and
rights for same-sex couples
environmentalism and all of those things
that there needed to be a correction at
that point in time but through the
seventies 80s and the 90s I think
there's a view that I'm sympathetic to
that there were what started as an
attempt to fix these very legitimate
grievances then began to overreach and
began to it was sort of couldn't stop
itself it was just looking for you know
any new possible identity any new way of
defining people by difference not by
what they had in common and sort of
liberalism turned into this kind of
really bad version of itself it just
kind of you know when on steroids and it
and it started to overreach and I look
at really what's been happening in
Europe it's really since the late 80s
through the 90s into the 2000s as as a
correction to that as gradually
conservative and populist parties began
to then sort of backlash against hyper
liberalism I think what worries me about
where we are today is we're now
beginning to see if you like the
backlash to the backlash which is now
liberals in the US and the UK and
elsewhere doubling down and say actually
I'm not going to do the one thing that
will get us through this period which is
compromise I'm not going to acknowledge
the things that we have in common look
at even the first few days of Boris
Johnson's Premiership you can look at
the Johnson Premiership and you can say
well actually there are a lot of things
here that we were asking for for a long
time the rights of EU nationals
guaranteed more help for international
students scrapping the net migration
target adopting very preferable
favorable visa regimes for NHS workers
and so on and so on and so and all of
these things that we spend three years
as a little less screaming about
shrieking about actually the
Conservatives are not doubling down on
the sort of hostile environment they
seem to be making some concessions well
why don't we spend some time
acknowledging that focus
on that building some compromise around
that instead of saying what they're
saying now which is Britain is turning
into Hungary right Britta the liberal
cut and catastrophizing Britain is
sliding into authoritarianism because
it's just the view is not able or Torah
to to acknowledge some of the things
where there is common ground so anyway I
think in general what worries me is
you're now beginning to see partly
through the politics of climate change
which i think is going to be fascinating
but also to the rise of green movements
in Europe through the direction of the
Democrat voters that I've talked to in
the Democrat activists and also I think
through the direction of the British
British Labour Party you're seeing a
backlash to that backlash and that the
end result of all of that would just be
polarization because you've got these
two sides now basically dug in and
they've got they've got representatives
they've got political parties that have
adapted to speak on their behalf and the
compromise the middle ground the nuance
the ambiguity gets shut down which is
why I find some of the academic debates
so frustrating because academics often
adopt the same binary language as the
populist by saying you're either you're
either with us on the left or you're
legitimizing hey nationalism and hatred
there's no marketplace of ideas there
it's it's just as binary as the populist
that many of them are studying so I
think it's that that does genuinely
worry me because we need to try and
figure out a way of propping up demand
every time so it's the second time we've
interviewed you and every time I come
away and I think I should have asked him
that question and I know it's a very
difficult question to us and his
prediction some protections always
oldest because it's so difficult to get
wrong but nevertheless I'm going to ask
you it are we watching the slow death of
the EU not the death of the EU but the
the challenges facing the European Union
possibly the contraction of the European
Union I think a beginning not ending I'm
very pessimistic about the European
Union for many ways
I wouldn't describe myself as a brexit
here but I was certainly I've certainly
spent the last few years
questioning whether the European Union
has what it takes to remedy the multiple
challenges that it's facing and you know
those challenges are well-known its
aging it's not productive enough it's
divided between I mean being quite crude
but east and west over values north and
south over economic redistribution there
has not appeared much solidarity at key
moments when it was required and there
doesn't appear to be much of a an answer
coming from sort of elite within the EU
sphere in terms of what to do about any
of that and when you look at the longer
term kind of projections and trends with
regards to the pressure that the EU and
the euro is only going to come under
from you know us-china from population
change in Africa from a cent of Central
and Eastern European states the
populating shrinking the EU needs a
radical forward-looking sensible policy
agenda and and foremost needs leadership
and currently there is a leadership
vacuum within the European Union the
response to brac see I think has been
very revealing kind of inability to
really digest what is at the heart the
route of Euro skepticism and populism if
anything this year 2019 populism is
consolidated I mean I was just struck
and on Twitter during the European
elections is watching a number of people
trying to kind of spin this as being a
really bad set of elections for parties
that are Euroskeptic I mean when you saw
the share of seats in the European
Parliament for Euroskeptic parties has
now reached a record high and we've seen
party systems that we were told when
when I was in my PhD at least you know
early 2000s places like Germany and
Sweden you know have basically
fragmented and have become much less
stable kind of political systems
meanwhile you know populist in control
of Italy breaking through in Spain which
again we were always told wouldn't
happen and if anything the kind of
harder right government
it's in Central and Eastern Europe have
become stronger but there's a lot of
wishful thinking out there there's a lot
of people that actually don't want to
you know they get very excited about the
rise of a couple of green parties but
aren't actually I would argue at least
in the public conversation and
discussion still I mean we talked about
this in national populism still sort of
covering themselves with comfort
blankets it's all about imports from
China it's all about austerity and the
legacy of the financial crisis whereas I
think actually this era of disruptions
just beginning you know and this is not
going to be an easy answer for the
European Union I don't think it will
collapse at all I think it will have to
contract further and I suspect one or
two states in southern Europe probably
won't won't be in the European Union
20-30 years from now and I'm happy to be
wrong about that but I just don't think
it's sustainable to keep for example
Italians living the way they're living
not having any significant increase in
living standards and not feeling
respected and you said earlier on of our
language respect dignity and recognition
are words that we don't hear a lot about
when we're talking about election
outcomes and why people are revolting
but but they're incredibly important and
emotion in politics is incredibly
important and in my world in political
science we really don't talk about
emotion in in as big a way as
psychologists do because we think it's
all right institutions and party vessels
and leaders and but when you think about
emotion as a potent tool of voting
behavior then in Europe you know I think
it's it's potentially going to be very
significant you know blame you know hope
aspiration and all of these things I
think the European Union will struggle
to to respond to them it's been a great
interview and thank you so much for
coming back you guys can see why we were
delighted to have Matt back on the show
before we let you go which we must do
now because you're a busy man you've
been all over the the TV studios for the
last week talking to people about what's
happened with last question we always
ask is what is the one thing that no
one's talking about
we should be talking about and it can be
absolutely anything at all well I think
lots of people are talking about it but
I I'm now increasingly convinced I think
the politics of climate change is going
to be the next huge big disruptive
moment in in in our political world I
think we haven't even begun to
interrogate what that means for
traditional party allegiances give us a
30-second summary of the whole thing
what's going to happen with that well I
think it's going to become partly a new
culture war I think the conservative
parties are going to have to move very
quickly on it
to say actually the most conservative
thing in the world is to be thinking
about environmentalism and you know in a
reasonable sensible way and I think
we're gonna have some really entrenched
as an issue I think is going to bring
out the generational I don't say
conflicts with the generational tensions
that we can already see emerging if you
look at generations these views on
though on that issue versus the baby
boomers you know some real interesting
tensions emerging there and you know in
terms of how it's going to disrupt
political systems you know green parties
perhaps eating into traditional
left-wing parties to a much greater
degree and how the right responds to
that it has to start thinking about that
now because I think the pace of that
political change will be will be will be
very very very big very quickly
fascinating stuff make sure if you want
to D in depth analysis of all this stuff
make sure to get Matt's book national
populism the revolt against liberal
democracy follow him on Twitter your
great follow in twitter man during the
election you're posting all the polls
and stuff and i'm sure there'll be lots
of stuff that you're putting out so
follow me on twitter we'll put we'll put
the his username in in the video and we
will see you in a week's time with
another brilliant episode take care see
you next week guys thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word